okay so welcome everyone i'm bettina and
i'm currently working on a computer
vision application to support the work
of biomedical curators
one of the most challenging aspects in
this project was to
make many decisions due to
after
subdividing the overall task into
different subtasks we had a lot of tools
or methods which we could apply to solve
the different problems
and so
on the one hand
we had the advantage to having more
tools or methods at all disposal but at
the other time we needed to make
decisions and more decisions than having
an obvious path to go
and in today's talk i would like to
yeah highlight
on behalf of this project a bit of the
strategies that i used which
make us to converge to a solution much
faster
in the end
so what does a biomedical curator do
i will show you a
video of it
it's rather condensed way what they do
in their process of extracting data like
for instance protein names or
kinetic parameters that they later fill
into a database
they highlight text and some of them
work on digital documents
so on their computer but many of them
still use actual paper
and so the general idea is to
form them so we have a video stream
and to extract the highlighted areas and
the text from them
in the end and do something with it for
further downstream
applications okay so
the central idea i think what i would
like
highlight is
that using fast feedback loops and some
additional strategies that supplement
this
helps to find faster solutions to
many tasks
and what i mean by fast feedback loops
is
we start with the first naive solution
let's say minimal example
and this helps us to not overthink our
problem
but rather get started soon getting
hands-on
and then use evaluation in form of for
instance
applying
our solution to data in my case these
were images
and find the next steps to take the next
methods we should apply because now we
have a first feeling of the real problem
and do this many times so rather use
fast iterations
and in each step evaluate our current
solution
intimate intermediate solution and then
make some appropriate changes
to it
and this also helps us to identify edge
cases and usually we do not see
all the implications of a task
at the first time we think about it
so we have a certain mental model and
during our process we need to update it
and to fill in missing information
and to do this we can for instance
test
with
at best realistic data and we not always
have this data
at hand maybe we can generate it
or we can ask experts or for instance
our future users
to supply us with them
and this helps as i already said a bit
of
finding edge cases and
finding missing data in our mental model
of the actual tasks
but
this will not always help us to find
out um
the
um
yeah
questioning our own thinking errors so
i highly encourage
everyone to
not only ask your internal rubber duck
but also talk to experts for instance in
the field in my case for instance i was
not working in computer vision before so
it really helped to get some additional
experience from people in my group which
had further knowledge on specific parts
for instance image processing methods
and to run down my ideas
and get another perspective on it
and actually
it helped also a great deal to have
curators in my group that are supposed
to use this application in the end
and they supplied me with some data of
their own so some images
in from their workflow
and yeah
based on that
um i needed still to evaluate with the
trade-offs
in mind
in the first place you wanted to have a
real-time
application
and
in the several steps of
building this application we had
different components
so imagine we would have an application
which which consists of four different
components and
we would have to
always have in mind that we have an
upper limit of our running time
and while building every
step
of this pipeline we needed to keep that
in mind to not exceed the napoli limit
okay so let me go back to the general
idea
so one of the problems
was
that
i wanted to have the
curators in the end
not
i didn't want to interrupt their
workflows so much because i think that's
highly critical if someone will
implement the solution
and
one of the things i wanted to give was
them the freedom to set the camera
somewhere else
so the angle doesn't matter so much
and also use different highlighter
colors not everyone will use for
instance yellow highlighting colors at
least not from what i saw and what
people told me as well
so i needed to keep that in mind
and the
actual pipeline we use looks like this
we have an input which consists of a
video stream
so basically a series of images
and
for the text extraction part we use the
original pdf as a reference
and extract images of every page from it
and then
match
our current image to this page
and do a feature extraction on both of
them to find the mapping between both
of these images
and as you already saw before you can
have a certain kind of skewedness you
don't have a perfect angle of incidence
of 90 degrees for instance
but
yeah there's a
lower limit to it of course and it also
depends on the feature extraction method
you're using
but
it gives the people more freedom
how they can use this in the end how
they can set up their camera for
instance use a smartphone camera at some
point
as well
and in the next step we need to detect
the highlights and then find the
corresponding bounding boxes
segment this
and then map them in back into the
reference image we took in the first
place
and extract the text from
and after that generating some output
they requested
some human readable formats and
i wanted to have some computer reward
formats as well for further downstream
applications
to come
okay so let me show you a few of the
details of this
problem
one of the challenges i already
mentioned was i wanted to have them
different colors at their disposal
and the camera not to set up
at a specific point
and
due to wanting a real-time
application we
and the upper limit of running time
we needed to have a fast feature
detection method and as a baseline i
used a sift feature detector
feature detection method
but it is way too slow for what you
would like to have
so i tested
different feature extraction methods
and for this i used this concept of fast
feedback loops to evaluate in every step
but first choose based on bit of
research done into the topic of feature
detectors
and go from there
and the robustness of the application is
also key which brings me to i think the
most
challenging part of this project
at the current time because if you have
different illumination conditions
this highly complicates this whole setup
i mean for instance in machine
intelligence they usually use so as far
as i know
a specific
illumination condition
under which they all took the photos of
their products and evaluate if they are
in some
if there are some errors and made in the
production process
but in our case i mean if you have a
window at home you know that
uh sometimes the weather is sunny and
sometimes it's cloudy and as you can see
for instance in the examples the upper
image is taken under cloudy weather
conditions and the lower one under sunny
conditions
so you have to build a test set which
incorporates all these possibilities to
find a really robust solution
and then
one of the curators supplied me with
some test images as well
and after running my solution on them i
came to the conclusion that i forgot
something
and
the
my own images
to test my solution on were taken
with a webcam in the first place and it
takes raw camera data without any post
processing
but
the post processing software in the
cameras of the curators
i didn't
inc incorporate into my solution at this
very time when i first started out
so i needed to make corrections further
down
and in addition
using different highlighter colors is
also complicating this process way more
than i would have expected in the first
place so
finding a robust solution
is
highly complicated
for instance opposed to
matching an image to reference if you
have no further constraints
so the last
part the text extraction
was also
quite interesting because
the pdf parsing
serves here as kind of a baseline
and the problem
in this kind of area is that in
biomedical literature you very often
have superscripted or subscripted
characters
and
maybe you know how pdf format works or
maybe you don't but it's not intended to
work in the direction i'm trying to go i
am trying to reverse the whole process
of extracting the text whereas it was
intended to put on text and render it in
some way for
us people to have a nice
document experience
and as you can see the superscript and
character superscripted and subscript
characters aren't very well extracted
so the next idea was to use optical
character recognition on it and we use
tether rect
but
the
models trained well let's let's say the
models out there which you can use out
of the box but tether act are trained on
for instance wikipedia english wikipedia
and as you can imagine english wikipedia
also doesn't include very much
superscripted or subscript characters
the current solution we will are going
to use is to reclassify
the
subscripted characters were super
scripted characters based
on the fact that for certain modes
tereza tesseract can give you
confidence levels
for
each single character it recognizes and
then you can threshold based on them
on a confidence level and
reclassify it for instance using a very
lightweight pi torch model you have to
train before
and
this will hopefully give us
a
yeah
better
experience
than if they have to
copy it
directly from a pdf or put it in
manually because in the end we would
like to have a better workflow for the
user than they have already
so in all of these
more detailed problem i showed you
we used this
yeah
feedback loop
to
quickly find a solution
because usually there are many
solutions or methods out there
especially for the part i showed you
before
with the highlight detection
we stick together different low-level
image processing methods and you can
do a lot of these
um to find a solution but you would like
to find
a good working solution at least good
enough for your own use case
and
hopefully in find a time to get this
working fast
okay so
i hope this gives you some inspiration
if you are not already doing this on
your own in your own projects as well
or maybe you have some thoughts on
extraction of
text from documents
i hope
i could
help inspire you a bit and i would like
to thank you with this
stay curious and
please
come forward if you like to ask me some
questions you can also walk up to the
pilot's booth where i will
be later on or catch me somewhere here
at the conference or write me
feedback encouraged
thank you so much patina we have
a couple of questions first one is what
is the benefit of using video data
individual images seem to be enough
okay
i need to clarify the question so is the
question
why don't we use
just snapshots
i believe so to realize it's hard to ask
in principle we do
we don't take every frame
we just
so the
i want
only if you want to go further
down this path but
um the idea is to detect when the user
hand vanishes so for instance
we can use optical flow to do something
like this
and then take the next frame and analyze
it
so
um basically we basically we use
separate images only one frame at a time
and not analyze the whole
video
but we have the setup to get these
snapshots
okay
great um
then the next question is how does it
work when a document contains images
figures or crafts
a highlighted box is detected with the
same accuracy that's a research question
i believe
this is a great question this is yeah
with my so with my first solution this
wouldn't work so i i tried this out
later on
[Music]
so
to
and then we stick together another
uh
several different
low-level image processing methods for
instance using differences of images and
then thresholding
for
to remove some noise as well so
this helps for instance with the figure
part if you can find the same
parts and threshold everything else
which is
which has not been in the image before
then you can find the
uh highlighted areas at least from the
point of time
before so from the frame before
you took okay um next question do the
curators add labels to the boxes or
they just detect keywords related to
chemistry
um
i'm not sure how this question is meant
i mean
they
so in it's not supposed to change their
workflow at least not in the at the
current point in time i mean it's
it makes it more improbable that people
will use it
they don't label
anything um so
they just highlight
text and later on they
fill some
things into a database sometimes they
even have to calculate i think some
reaction parameters or something like
this
so one of the problems
for instance to do
end-to-end deep learning on this is
some of the knowledge from these experts
cannot be directly extracted
um and the database
formula so the formula fields have
certain kind of labels so for instance
there might be an actual actual mapping
if we have
additional labels for
some of the extracted
text
words for instance like it's a protein
or something like this but
i think this uh would need
a deep learning
solution and what i
was
to do was um having a lower level
solution so
uh yeah didn't do deep to end to end
learning okay um next question during
the pre-processing did you compute
differences between images with
without a markers to extract the marked
areas uh would it be an idea at all
can you repeat please yeah doing the
pre-processing did you compute
differences between images with versus
without markers
to extract
the marked areas is this an idea
yes this was actually the first thing i
tried because i figured that you can
do differences as well so i think with
images
but
so happy to still time
um four minutes yeah okay
um let me show you something related to
that
okay so
in the video you will see my hand and it
it introduces some shadows
which introduces when you take a
difference of images artifacts
and
at first
thresholding
i tried thresholding them but it didn't
work quite well so
given my knowledge at the point in time
um i didn't stick to this
but implemented some other low-level
solution
and then came back to this idea so
now
taking differences of images and adding
some other low-level methods is the way
we
use
okay um
how exactly does the reference mapping
work
okay
um
okay so
imagine you just load
down a paper from
one of the open access
sites for instance like
and
you can then convert every pdf page into
an image
and then then you can do feature
extraction based on every page
and store them up front
and
when you process this stream of images
and take one of the frames
you can extract the features there as
well and then map the features to each
other and find the mapping so basically
the transformation matrix
after that and use this further down for
instance what i showed you to map the
corresponding
bounding boxes to the reference and to
extract the text from there
okay um
then the other question what languages
do you plan to support why are i buy
robust solution
well at the current time i think
we
would support english but i mean this
project is intended to be an open
science project source code isn't
published
publicly accessible yet
but the idea is that this will be that
way in the future and if you would like
to request other
languages
i think maybe
this
could work somehow i mean depends a bit
maybe on the language
but
probably
would be possible
especially with additional contributions
for instance
from other people
and then what is the downstream
application of this application that is
what the boxes are used for after
detecting them
okay so um we are not completely decided
at the current point in of time um
what
yeah is the overall end result
some people have certain ideas maybe
other creators will have another opinion
on that
[Music]
some ideas
are in the corner of for instance
filling data bases up front
but as i explained i think this would
rather use a need a deep learning entire
solution which could also be made
possible maybe
but for instance we could augment the
original pdf papers with additional
information for instance do
named entity recognition on the
extracted
text
and then do some entity linking into
another knowledge database and for
instance
put
back links into the original original
document so that you can click on them
and then be transferred
to the knowledge base and the
for instance id of some protein
and then last question did you try to
reverse engineer the classification to
see what your model is trained on and
that is high focus on white background
have you done
no i didn't so far okay maybe then a
suggestion for the future good
thank you for your talk and your work